So the family and I are going to the lake today.
I've got my little, like,
cute little, honestly,
like, dirty dancing outfit.
Um, but I wanted to try a new lip combo
because I've been seeing the Sabrina Carpenter lip everywhere,
and I think it's really pretty,
and I wanna try it out. So I'm using some NYX products.
NYX products. Forgot to put blush on.
I'm using my merit beauty.
It's amazing. Okay,
so this is the NYX line. Loud in Global Citizen,
just right there.
And Cupid's bow.
I just wanna blend it a little.
And this is the NYX Butter gloss in creme brulee.
Oh, that's really pretty.
Now, I know the light in here is shit,
but if you're looking for, like,
a nude glossy lip, this is great.
There's some better lighting. What do we think?